اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه ضمن الساعات المتواصله من
العربيه لتغطيه التطورات المتفاقمه في
السودان طبعا الاشتباكات يا طاهر بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه
تتواصلوا لليوم الثالث على التوالي فيما
فشلت الى الان جهود الوساطه المحليه
والدوليه اعداد الضحايا بازدياد مستمر
فبحسب المبعوث الاممي الى السودان قتل نحو
180 مدنيا وعسكريا واصيب نحو
1800 منذ بدايه الاشتباكات
[موسيقى]
قال يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع للعربيه ان المعركه مع قوات
الجيش ستكون فاصله خاصه وان قوات الدعم
السريع اصبحت تسيطر على كافه المباني
والمقر الرئيسيه اضافه الى مطار الخطوبه
الى ان البيت الابيض يقول الان للعربيه لا
حل عسكريا للازمه في السودان نتابع
مستمره
لكن التوقيت الان بالنسبه للمبادرات نحن
نرحب بكل مبادره لكن الان المعركه تدور
الان وانا اتحدث معك كمان المعرفه
هنالك
توقيت مثل هذه المبادرات لكن الان الوقت
للمعركه نحن ندخل معركه فاصله مع
الانقلابيين مع الاسلاميين مع الذين
اختطفوا القرار في الجيش نحن نسيطر الان
على القياده العامه بالكامل بكل مبانيها
وخارج اسوارها نحن متواجدين نسيطر على
مطار الخرطوم نسيطر على القصر الرئاسي
نسيطر على ايذاء امراضنا ايذاء الاذاعه
والتلفزيون نسيطر على قاعده فؤاد سيدنا
الجويه نسيطر على جبل اولياء نصيطر على كل
المداخل الكباري المؤديه الى ولايه
الخرطوم الى مدينه الخرطوم
بالمقابل نفى العميد نبيل عبد الله الناطق
باسم الجيش السوداني للعربيه ادعاءات قوه
الدعم السريع بالسيطره على اجزاء من مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه والقصر
الجمهوري وقصر الضيافه
نؤكد انه لا صح اطلاقا
لاستيلاء او سيطره مديشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القياده العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه التعذيب مضلله الامر الثاني
نحن نؤكد اننا المسلحه لاننا قوات محترفه
وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما بجميع
قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات نحن
نتقيد تماما بمقررات القانون الدولي
الانساني قانون النزاعات المسلحه في هذا
النزاع المسلح
[موسيقى]
والان المندوب الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده تقول بانه القتال في السودان يهدد
المسار السياسي وينضم الينا من الخرطوم
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم
نبدا معك طبعا اخر التطورات الميدانيه
نعم اخر التطورات الميدانيه هنا في
الخرطوم هدوء نسبي في الاجواء السودانيه
بعد ان شهدت مجموعه من الطائرات التي تشن
هجوما على مجموعه او على مجموعات من قوات
الدعم السريع تتمركز في مناطق مختلفه
وجاءت مضادات الطيران التي ردت على هذه
الطائرات
وامتلات سماء الخرطوم بالالوان الناريه
لمضادات الطيران قبل قليل لاي قبل ساعه
تقريبا من الان بعيدا للافطار بقليل
انطلقت هذه المواجهه هذه المره ليست في
الارض وانما في سماء الخرطوم بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش بعد ذلك
الدعم السريع واكد انه اسقط طائره في ام
درمان بهذه المضادات ومصادر من الجيش ايضا
نفت سقوط هذه الطائره حتى هذه اللحظه لكن
لم يدلي الطرفا باي ادله توحي بسقوط هذه
الطائره او عدم سقوطها طيب سالم الان
المعركه يبدو انها ستطول هناك تحضيرات لما
هو اسوا بالنسبه الى الناس على الاقل كيف
يفعلون ذلك من خلال تحضير انفسهم
وعائلاتهم
لمالات الامور في الايام المقبله على
الصعيد الانساني
بكل تاكيد هذا الوضع على انساني هو بكل
تاكيد اقولها هو الاسوا حقيقه او هو
الاكثر سوءا ويزداد سوءا يوما بعد اخر ولا
ادري من اين ابدا هذا الوضع الانساني ان
نبداه بالمشافي والمصححات المستشفيات مثلا
او نبداه بالخدمات التي يفترض انها تقدم
للمواطن كالمياه والكهرباء اما نبداه من
اي صيغه تشاء من الوضع الاقتصادي نفسه
فهذه الحرب جاءت بعد ظروف اقتصاديه يمر
بها المواطن الصعبه جدا لتزيد هذه
التعقيدات اكثر من ذلك اكثر مما هو عليه
الحال الان بدانا نشاهد
الطوابير والصفوف امام المخابز نسبه لان
اصلا الدقيق الذي يوزع في المخابز كان
ياتي بناء على حصص معينه اسبوعيه تاتي هذه
الحصص ان لم تخل الذاكره كذلك
الامدادات الغذائيه كلها باشكالها في
المحل التجاريه والبقالات
كلها تاتي بحصص معينه بالقدره التي يستطيع
التاجر ان يحملها السوبر ماركت او الدكان
الذي يبيع فيه هذا الامداد توقف الامداد
لمواد الغذائيه امداد الدقيق حتى امداد
المواد البتروليه اليوم شاهدنا ايضا
فحينما كانت هناك حركه ولو بسيطه في بعض
شوارع الخرطوم ان محلات الطرمبات الوقود
او محطات بيع الوقود تقف فيها سيارات دون
المحطات تعمل كذلك
المواد الغذائيه كذلك هناك شح فيها هناك
رفوف في البقالات اصبحت خاليه
انتهت هذه البضاعه دون ان يستطيع التاجر
ان ياتي بضاعه اخرى هذا ما يدعو كل
المجتمع الدولي وكل الذين يتحدثون عن
الامر الانسانيه الان تتجدد الاشتباكات
مره اخرى نستمع اليها الان وهي اصوات
لمضادات طائرات نراها هنا
بحري الان بدات مره اخرى حسب يعني معرفتك
اليوم ما هي الاسلحه او حتى يعني هل تم
اللجوء الى الطائرات الى الطيران الجوي
السوداني اليوم الاسلحه التي كانت هي
المحور بنزاع اليوم تحديدا
والان تمتلك وكان انقطع الصوت قليلا ام ان
المواطنين الذين صوروها نتابع نتابع معك
سالم كان انقطع صوت قليلا ولكن عدت الينا
اذا كان في اي معلومات اضافيه في الموضوع
الذي سالت عنه زميله راويه يمكن ان نتابع
فيها ونريد ان نسال ايضا
بالتزامن مع صوت السلاح الذي لا يعلو عليه
صوت في في هذه الايام منذ بدء المعركه الا
انه لابد من السؤال ايضا عن
الجو السياسي مع بدء توافذ
الوسطاء ان كان يعني داخل او في الخارج
يبدو انقطع الاتصال لا يسمعني سالم
الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم قد نعود
اليك في سياق هذه الساعه او في ساعات اخرى
بطبيعه الحال ونتابع ما لدينا في هذه
الساعه مما نقلته شبكه سي ان ان عن رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني والقائد العام
للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وهو قوله ان
الهجوم الذي شنته قوات الدعم السريع في
الايام الاخيره وهي محاوله للانقلاب
البرهان ان قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلوه تمرد ضد الدوله واذا تم القبض
عليه ستتم محاكمته امام القضاء
بالمقابل قال قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان ان قوته تتخذ جميع الاجراءات
اللازمه لضمان امن المدنيين وسلامتهم هذا
وطلب دبل عبر سلسله تغريدات على حسابه في
تويتر طلب المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك الفوري
وتدخل ضد ما اسماها بجرائم الحرب او جرائم
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان والان يا طاهر يعني مصادر من
السفاره الامريكيه للعربيه تقول بانه
الدعم السريع استهدف عربه مصفحه تابعه لنا
ولا اصابات يتابعه للسفاره الامريكيه طبعا
كان الموقف الامريكي اليوم موقف البيت
الابيض كما قلنا الدعوه الى ايقاف العنف
فورا وايقاف الاقتتال بين الطرفين وياتي
هذا الخبر العاجل الان عن مصادر من
السفاره الامريكيه للعربيه المواجهه
العسكريه هذه بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع راويه تشهد عشرات الاخبار
والاعلانات غير الحقيقيه كما تابعنا في كل
ايام الماضيه والساعات الماضيه وذلك في
اطار محاوله كلا الطرفين زعزعه ثقه الطرف
الاخر بنفسه والتسبب بانهياره نفسيا
وبالتالي تاثير على مجريات المعارك والتي
يؤكد خبراء انها قد تطول ولا يسهل حسمها
عسكريا
مقاتله تشق سماء الخرطوم قبل ان تلقي
بصاروخ على هدف ما
مروحيتان تظفران بمركبه عسكريه على الارض
[موسيقى]
مشهد حقيقي واخر مزيف وقد يكون العكس فكل
شيء في الحرب مباح التزييف والبيانات
الخادعه او حتى الكاذبه سلاح فقط
[موسيقى]
هنا تنشر قوات الدعم السريع مشهدا لطائره
مروحيه سقطت ودبابه انفجرت
فيرد الجيش ببيان نافيا صحه هذه الاخبار
وهنا ينشر الجيش صوره يقول انها تثبت هروب
احمد التي من مخباه بعد هروب طاقم حراسته
ليؤكد الاخير بنفسه انه يقود المعارك من
الخرطوم كل طرف يحاول اظهار تفوقه في
المعركه وانهيار الخصم واقتراب الحسم فيما
يؤكد خبراء ان المعركه سوف تطول
يمكن السيطره في نهايه المطاف على المناطق
المفصليه في الخرطوم بما لها من رمزيه
ويتحول النزاع مره اخرى الى نزاع في
الهوامش والمدن الاخرى ويستطيل امد الصراع
في السودان وهذا ما نخشاه في الحرب
النفسيه تستهدف ثقه الجنود ومعنويات
الافراد فيسارع كل طرف لنشر تسجيلات تظهر
انشقاق او استسلام القاده
اؤكد بانني
لم ولن تصرح لاي جهه
اعلاميه بما يجري الان من احداث باعتبار
ضابطا بالقوات المسلحه
وليست متحدثا باسم اي جهه
متواجد مع قوات الدعم السريع ومنذ وجودي
وجدت كل تعامل جيد
والكرم
ولم يساعد اي شيء الحمد لله
خلال اليومين الماضيين تضاربت الانباء
بشان السيطره على الاماكن الاستراتيجيه
والمواقع الحساسه في الخرطوم وخارج بيانات
تؤكد واخرى تنفيذ معارك حسمت ومواقع سلمت
وكل ذلك كانت تزييفا على الورق لكن على
الارض ما زالت المدافع تدك والقنابل تنفجر
والمباني تشتعل والضحايا يتساقطون
اذا راويه عطفا على الخبر الذي ذكرتيه قبل
قليل فان مصادر السفاره الامريكيه قالت
للعربيه ايضا ان الدعم السريع استهدف
سيارتنا عن قصد بمئه رصاصه هذا ربما يعني
يجعل الموقف الامريكي اكثر تشددا مع الدعم
السريع
بنشرتنا الجيش السوداني نشر صورا لما قيل
انها لاسرى من قوات الدعم السريعه اشاره
الى ان جنسيات اجنبيه بين المعتقلين
[موسيقى]
الدنيا
عشان كده انا قلنا لكم
والله
اذا اجت السوداني يعلن عبر التلفزيون رسمي
سيطره على سلاح المدرعات بحي جبره جنوب
الخرطوم واي جديد نريده عبر الاخبار
العاجله على الشاشه اذا لليوم الثالث على
التوالي تواصلت المعارك بين قوات الدعم
السريعه وقوات الجيش السوداني الاقتتال
انتشر في مختلف ارجاء السودان سيما
العاصمه الخرطوم وسط تضارب للانباء حول
مواقع سيطره كل طرف
رقعه المعارك تتسع في السودان عده مواقع
باتت مسرحا للاقتتال سواء داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم او خارجها فخريطه الصراع مليئه
بالنقاط الساخنه اكثر المعارك شراسه تدور
رحاها بالعاصمه الخرطوم ابرزها مقر
القياده العامه للجيش والذي يوجد في شمال
العاصمه فالاقتتال مستمر في محيط مقر
القياده وسط انباء متضاربه حول جهه
المسيطره على المبنى مبنى اخر في العاصمه
الخرطوم تحول الى ساحه صراع بين الطرفين
وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي يوجد في
المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه ولا يزال
الوضع غير واضح هناك فقوه الدعم اعلنت
سيطرتها عليه قبل ان ينفي ذلك الجيش
السوداني شمالا دائما لكن هذه المره في
الضفه الاخرى من نهر النيل وتحديدا ام
درمان حيث دارت اشتباكات في محيط مبنى
التلفزيون بعد محاوله قوات الدعم السريع
السيطره عليه لكن الشاشه السوداني اعلن
فيما بعد سيطرته على المبنى بشكل كامل
مجهضا محاولات قوات الدعم وبعيدا عن
العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه المره في شمال
البلاد وتحديدا في مدينه مرويا التي شهدت
اندلاع الشراره الاولى للازمه فمصير مطار
ماروي الذي يقع في الجزء الشرقي من
المدينه لا يزال معلقا في ظل اعلان كل طرف
بسطه سيطرته عليها والاكيد ان حرب المدافع
والاسلحه في السودان توازيها حرب معلومات
اسلحتها المقاطع المصوره والبيانات
وسام الذهبي العربيه
يضم الجيش الجيش السوداني عددا من القاده
البارزين برئاسه الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان كما تضم قوات الدعم السريع التي
يتراسها محمد حمدان دقلو ونائبه وشقيقه
عبد الرحيم حمدان دقلو ضباطا ومستشارين
نتعرف عليه
[موسيقى]
حذر الامين العام للامم المتحده من ان
الوضع الانساني في السودان محفوف بالمخاطر
وكارثيه مطالبا الجامعه بضروره احترام
القانون الدولي وضمان سلامه وامن موظفي
الامم المتحده والعاملين في مجال
المساعدات الانسانيه
في السودان محفوف بالمخاطر وكارثه ندين
بشده سقوط قتلى وجرحى بين المدنيين
والعاملين في المجال الانساني واستهداف
ونهب المباني واذكر الجميع بضروره احترام
القانون الدولي وضمان سلامه وامن جميع
موظفي الامم المتحده والعاملين في مجال
المساعده الانسانيه اؤكد مره اخرى بان
الامم المتحده تقف الى جانب شعب السودان
وتقدم دعم الكامل لجهود استعاده الانتقال
الديمقراطي وبناء مستقبل سلمي وامن
دكتور حسن ابو طالب المنتصر في مركز
الاهرام لدراسات سياسيه والاستراتيجيه من
القاهره الان اهلا بك معنا دكتور
هل هناك صوت للحكمه للعقل في هذه الاثناء
ان لم يكن في الداخل في الاقليم قادر على
ان يرفع صوته
يعني الاقليم وخصوصا الدول العربيه
المركزيه الاساسيه في مصر والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات وايضا بعض
الدول الافريقيه المحيطه بالسودان لديها
صوت عقل عالي جدا وحكمه رشيده جدا الكنيه
المشكله ليست في هذه الاصوات العاقله
والرشيده في الاقليم المشكله الان هي في
الداخل السوداني كما راينا على خط
الانباء العاجله التي تنشرونها بين الحين
والاخر المبعوث الامم تحدث بصراحه شديده
على ان طرفي الصراع العسكريين في الداخل
السوداني لا يبديان اي رغبه للحوار او
الوساطه او لوقف اطلاق النار اذا فالمساله
والمشكله هنا هي في الداخل السوداني نفسه
في القيادات العسكريه وكما استمعنا الى
المستشار السياسي لقائد القوات الدعم
السريعه التي تحدث فيها ان هذه هي معركه
الحسم وانهم سوف ينتصبون وانهم يسيطرون
على كل مقالات القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه هذا معناه اننا امام
مرحله من الصراع الامد للاسف الشديد سوف
تستمر الامور هي على هذا النحو لفتره اطول
مما هو يعني يبدو وبالتالي فالمشكله هنا
ليست في الخارج المشكله هي في الداخل يعني
اذكر بالامس كانت هناك مبادره مصريه معلنه
بالتنسيق مع جنوب السودان وايضا بالتنسيق
مع بعض الاطراف الامميه
المشاركه في الحوار الداخلي في السودان
وهذه المبادره لم تستقبل حتى هذه اللحظه
من اين من الطرفين باي درجه من درجات
التفاعل الايجابي وبالتالي فنحن امام يعني
مفارقه الاقليم حريص على السودان حريص على
شعبه حريص على موارده لكن للاسف الشديد
الاطراف الفاعله في الداخل السوداني ليست
بمثل هذه الدرجه من الحكمه وبالتالي ما
سيناريوهات الحلول المطروحه او التي
سيقبلها الطرفين يعني فرص النجاح والشروط
والاهم الجهه المقبوله من الجيش السوداني
وايضا قوات الدعم
يعني نحن لدينا اطراف امميه واطراف
اقليميه واطراف افريقيه وبالتالي هذا
التنوع ايضا اضافه الى الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وايضا الضغط السياسي والمعنوي
التي تمارسه بعض القوى الكبرى مثل الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالتالي فنحن امام توزيعه كبيره
جدا جدا من العناصر الخارجيه انا في تصوري
ان هذا نوع من انواع التشتت الجميع عليها
ان ينسق فيما بينه وبالتالي التواصلات ما
بين هذه القوه مهم جدا جدا جدا تحت مظله
الامم المتحده واتحاد الافريقي وجماعه
الدول العربيه اذا حدث هذا النوع من
التنسيق بين هذه الاطراف بحيث ان تكون
هناك قوه ضغط واحده وفي افكار واحده
ومبادره واحده ربما في هذه الحاله يمكن ان
يكون هناك بصيص امل لكن يظل الامر متعلق
بالداخل هذه النقطه النقطه الثانيه هنا
نحن امام اولويه الاولويه الان المطروحه
على الساحه هي وقف اطلاق النار الاولويه
هي الحفاظ على الارواح السودانيه الاولويه
هي الحفاظ على الموارد السودانيه البسيطه
والهذيله وايضا يعني
توفير الحد الادنى من الدعم الانساني
والدعم المتعلق بالامكانيات الطبيه التي
يعني يجب ان تتوفر الان بسرعه عاجله هذا
الامر لن يستطيع احد ان يوفره للسودان في
اي موقع من موقعه الا اذا توقف وقف اطلاق
النار وكانت هناك لجنه امميه افريقيه
الدول العربيه تمارس نوع من انواع الرقابه
على من يعني لا يلتزم بهذا وقت اطلاق
النار هذه هي الاولويه
العمليه البحته ثم بعد ذلك اذا استمر وقف
اطلاق النار والالتزام به مع التنسيق
الدولي والاممي المختلفه الذي اشرت اليه
ربما يسمح هذا فيما بعد بممارسه ضغوط
مختلفه المستويات على الطرفين ليس فقط
للوقوع او يعني للعوده مره اخرى الى طاوله
الحوار وانما الالتزام بقواعد الاشتباك
وقواعد القوانين الدولي فيما يتعلق
بالمواجهات العسكريه التي قد تحدث في
الاماكن المدنيه هذا الامر مهم جدا جدا في
هذه المرحله اي حديث عن يعني عمليه سياسيه
فيما بعد ذلك لابد ان يؤجل الاولويه الان
هي وقف اطلاق النار وحمايه الارواح تمام
الجيش السودانيه اعلن عبر التلفزيون رسمي
قبل قليل اذا حسم معركه جبرا واعاده
السيطره على مخزن اسلحه واليات
بالعوده الى ما تفضلت به عن الدعم الخارجي
عن ان الحل في الداخل قبل اي دعم خارجي
لابد من الاشاره هنا الى هذا الدعم انه
كان
ولا يزال
لكل جهه كل جهه تدعمها جهه خارجيه ان كانت
اقليميه او دوليه ثم ثم ان الاتفاق
الخارجي غير متوفر فيما بين هذه الاطراف
الخارجيه على طبيعه الحل وعلى كيف يمكن ان
يكون المشهد السوداني السياسي والعسكري في
الفتره المقبله بسبب اختلاف الانتماءات
والولاءات ان كان في الداخل او في ما
تدعمه هذه الدول ما رايك
بالتاكيد انا اوافق على هذا التحليل وافق
ايضا على ان هذا التشتت في المبادرات وهذا
التشتت في او يعني هذه الدرجه العاليه من
المتدخلين كانوا هو السبب في ما وصل اليه
السوداني الان وبالتاكيد كانت هناك في
مرحله من المراحل كل طرف من الاطراف
الصراع الداخلي سواء القوى المدنيه التي
هي منقسمه على نفسها وايضا الاطراف
العسكريه التي هي ايضا اثبتت انها منقسمه
انقساما عقيقه عميقا فيما بينها كانت
تستدعي او كانت تقبل او كانت تحفز احد
الاطراف على ان يتدخل باعتباره وسيط او
باعتبار لديهم مبادره لكي تتشتت الجهود
وتشتت الجهود هو الذي اوصل السودان الى
هذا الامر اضافه الى الانقسامات الداخليه
السودانيه وبالتالي انا ما قصدته الان هو
ان يكون هناك تنسيق بين كل هذه الاطراف
المتدخله تحت مظله ثلاثه اساسيه الامم
المتحده الاتحاد الافريقي وجماعه الدول
العربيه اذا حدث هذا النوع من التنسيق بين
هذه المنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه والتي
تمثل ما يمكن نسميه الاطار العام للاقليم
والاطار العام للمصالح الدوليه ربما يكون
هناك مبادره واحده ربما يكون هناك عدم
التشتت وعدم يعني
الانقسامات وايضا المناورات التي يمكن ان
تحدث بين هذا الطرف وبالتالي هذه اولويه
من وجهه نظري التنسيق بين كل هذه الاطراف
المتدخله ووجهه نظر واحده او مبادره واحده
وايضا تحرك موحد ومشترك ومنسق دعني اشير
هنا الى
الحوار الذي تم اليوم او محادثات التي تمت
اليوم بين وزير الخارجيه المصري ونظيره في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه صحيح واتفق فيها
على تنسيق الجهود هذه نقطه مهمه جدا جدا
في هذا الاطار الجميع
يهمه استقرار السودان ولكن استقرار
السودان لن يكون بان يكون هناك اكثر من
طرف التدخل وكل متطرف وكل طرف يعني
يدفع الامور الى ناحيه مختلفه عن الناحيه
الاخرى الدكتور حسن ابقى معنا سنتابع
واياك حيث شهدت مدينه بحري تحليقه طائرات
الجيش السوداني لضرب مواقع للدعم السريع
وتظهر الصور مضادات طيران تتبع للدعم
السريع فيما افاده مصادر بان القصف تم
بالقرب من منزل محمد حمدان
الى ذلك نشرت قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان صورا لمروحيه تابعه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم واعلنت قوات الدعم
السريع انها اسقطت المروحيه بمضادات
الطائرات
ورصدت العربيه مدى الصعوبه التي تواجه
سكان العاصمه الخرطوم في الحصول على مياه
الشرب والطهي بعد توقف محطات المياه عاقبه
تضررها بسبب الاشتباكات الواسعه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعي في الخرطومه
[موسيقى]
الله يفتح عليكم
لفتت واصل عباس مسؤوله مديره جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر السوداني في ام درمان ثاني اكبر
المدن السودانيه الى ان القصف توقف في
مدينه ام درمان تحديدا وان الاوضاع استقرت
نسبه الى اليومين الماضيين من المعارك
واكدت عباس لوكاله انباء العالم العربي
توجه مئات المتطوعين الى المستشفيات
الحكوميه ككوادر مساعده في معالجه
المصابين جراء القصف وكانت جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر نشد الطرفين نزاع من الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع بالسماح للفرق الميدانيه
التابعه لها بمزاوله اعمالها الانسانيه
في مداخله مع العربيه اكد المدير الاقليمي
للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في افريقيا
بان الوضع في السودان صعب وخطير جدا واكيد
ما فيهم من المبالغه وقتها نقول انه الوضع
ممكن يصير كارثه اكثر واكثر اذا الوضع
الانساني ما استتب واذا
المجال للمنظمات الانسانيه خاصه العامله
بمجال الاغاثه الصحه المياه انه
تتدخل بطريقه سريعه جدا راح نشهد اكيد
انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم تسيير
المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف الشيء اللي
راح نواجهه قريبا
عدد ضحايا القتال الدائر في السودان في
تزايد وكذلك المشاكل التي ترهق كاهل
القطاع الطبيه في هذا البلد الذي يعيش
اصلا في ازمه اقتصاديه منذ فتره ليست
بالقصيره
السنه النيران ترتفع على بعد امتار قليله
من احدى مستشفيات الخرطوم هذه صوره من عدد
من الصور التي التقطها قمر مكسار الصناعي
لمجريات المعارك في العاصمه السودانيه
للاصابه لكن هذه الصوره لا تنقل تفاصيل
معاناه السودانيين داخل هذا المستشفى
وغيره من المنشات الطبيه نقص في المعدات
والدواء والاطباء ينامون على الارض بين
العمليات
مع مرور الساعات الصوره تزداد قتامه في
مستشفيات الخرطوم ومع سقوط ضحايا الجدد
خاصه ان الطواقم المداومه لم يتم تغييرها
منذ اربعه ايام ولكن الاخطر هو تاكل مخزون
بنك الدم حيث اضطر الاطباء الى الاقتصاد
فيه
فالجريح الذي يحتاج وحدتي دم لا يحصل الا
على واحده هذا حال مستشفيات العاصمه اما
الولايات البعيده فحال مستشفياتها اسوا
عدا عن قله الامكانيات وتزايد عدد
المصابين فان صفوف الطواقم الطبيه تتناقص
بسقوط اطباء قتلى وجرحى خلال الاشتباكات
ولكن الرصاص لا يعي ان نزيف طبيب واحد
سيؤدي الى نزيف المئات من السودانيين انس
نماسي العربيه
وللحديث حول رد الفعل الفرنسي اذا
التطورات بالسودان ينضم الينا من باريس
حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
اهلا بك معنا الليله حسين يعني الموقف
الفرنسي مما يحصل وان كان هناك جهود ربما
للوساطه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك راويه في الواقع ما صدر عن
الخارجيه الفرنسيه اليوم يؤكد من جهه ان
فرنسا تعرب عن قلقها البالغ ازاء ما يجري
في السودان وهي تتابع عن كثب ما يحصل هي
قلقه تحديدا لناحيه امن مواطنيها وفي هذا
المجال فان مركز الازمات التابعه لوزاره
الخارجيه وكذلك السفاره الفرنسيه في
الخرطوم يتابعان الوضع المتعلق بالمواطنين
الفرنسيين تكرر فرنسا كما جاء في بيان
الخارجيه الفرنسيه كما صرحت الناطقه باسم
الخارجيه تكرر باريس دعوتها لكل من الجيش
السوداني ولوحدات الدعم السريع الى وقف
القتال والى القبول بهدنه على الفور والى
ضمان ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه بامان
ودون عوائق والى احترام العاملين في
المجال الانساني وايضا الى انهاء التصعيد
والتوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار اخيرا
اشارت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى
ان تاريخ تدعم جهود شركاء السودان
الاقليميين والدوليين من اجل ايجاد مخرج
من الازمه هذا المخرج لا يكون براي
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الا من خلال العوده الى
عمليه سياسيه شامله ثم تشكيل حكومه
انتقاليه مدنيه ثم اجراء انتخابات عامه
كما جاء في تصريحات الناطقه باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه لم تاتي باريس حسين على ذكر
موضوع الجماعات الارهابيه التي يمكن ان
تستغل هذا الوضع لكي تعمل في داخل السودان
بما يمكن ان يكون له تاثير على دول
افريقيه اخرى تعتبر مناطق نفوذ
لباريس تاريخيا
لم تتحدث فرنسا رسميا عن هذا الامر لكن
وسائل اعلام فرنسيه كثيره تحدثت عن القلق
بهذا الشان واعطت تفاصيل حول احتمالات
خطره ولكن بيان الخارجيه الفرنسيه
وتصريحات الناطقه باسم الخارجيه
ركزت على النقاط التي ذكرتها طاهر وركزت
ايضا على مساله اخرى تتعلق باستهداف
العاملين في المجال الانساني فرنسا قلقه
جدا من استهداف العاملين مع برنامج الغذاء
العالمي تحديدا والعاملين ضمن فرق الامم
المتحده في السودان هي تكرر دعمها لهؤلاء
الذين لا يجب استهدافهم تحت اي ظرف من
الظروف كما اكدت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه التي ذكرت بضروره اعتماد
الاحترام الكامل للحمايه الواجبه لجميع
العاملين في المجال الانساني كانت تتحدث
تحديدا عن مقتل عده اشخاص
الذين يعملون مع برنامج الغذاء العالمي
وايضا مع منظمات غير حكوميه تتولى الاغاثه
الدوليه في السودان نعم احسان يعني على من
تضع فرنسا المسؤوليه فيما يحصل هل تضعها
على قوات الدعم السريع ام الجيش السوداني
الى مقالت اليه الامور وانفجار الوضع الى
صراع مسلح
طبعا فرنسا على المستوى الرسمي تنقى
بنفسها عن اتخاذ اي موقف مع هذا الطرف او
ذاك تركز على ضروره ان يوافق الطرفان فورا
على هدنه وهي عمدا الى الالتزام بوقف
لاطلاق النار ولكن التحليلات الكثيره التي
جاءت في وسائل اعلام فرنسيه اعتبرت ان ما
حصل كان متوقعا لان الامور كانت ذاهبه نحو
صدام اكيد بين الرجلين القويين في السودان
المقصود بهما طبعا عبد الفتاح البرهان
وحميده وقالت ان ما يجري حاليا طبعا وسائل
الاعلام الفرنسيه تتحدث عن ان ما يجري
حاليا لن ينتهي الا وفق عده سيناريوهات
احدها سيكون قبول وساطه اقليميه او دوليه
والسيناريو الاخر قد يكون بفوز احد
الطرفين عسكريا على الطرف الاخر
والسيناريو الاسوا هو
امتد هذا الصراع لعده اسابيع وربما لعده
اشهر شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
تحياتنا اليك شكرا
لا يزالوا عشرات الطلاب محاصرين في
الجامعات والمدارس اثثرى المعارك الدائره
بجانبهم لكن ما يزيد الوضع سوء ان هو
تساقم الوضع الانساني بسبب قله الغذاء
والماء
تشتد المعارك بالخارج ويشتد الخنق على
هؤلاء طلاب جامعات ربما يتلقون درسهم
الاقصى تحت سطوتي معركه حاصرتهم لعده ايام
ونجد جميع مبادره والمبادرات
السريع الوضع الراهن لانه نحن لا يوجد
لدينا مؤن لا يوجد لدينا مؤن ولا يوجد
لدينا اطعمه وفضلا من
الطائرات تجوب تجوب في الخارج
ونتخوف ونتخوف جدا جدا من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي
وانعدام المياه
هؤلاء ليسوا افضل حالا مضت ايام ثقيله
مراهقون لا تتجاوز اعمارهم الثلاثه عشر
عاما احتجزوا في مدرسه طالت دوام فيها لا
تهمهم قواعد الحرب بعيدا ولا هم مدركون
مناشدات عمت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لانقاذ طلاب الجامعات والمدارس والعاملين
فيها بعضها خلى من الطعام وحتى الاسعافات
الاوليه للمصابين
الهلال الاحمر السوداني اعلن عن اخراج 450
طالبا محاصرا من المدارس لكن يبقى العشرات
من طلاب الجامعات في وضع حرج بلا اي
مساعده
صمت المكان هنا بين الجدران تقابله معركه
على اشدها في الساحات
ففي احياء مدينه الخرطوم تستمر الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ما
اودى بحياه نحو 100 مدني واصابه 400 اخرين
وسط مناشدات من نقابه الاطباء بفتح ممرات
انسانيه لنقل المصابين وتسهيل وصول
الاطباء الى المستشفيات غيداء السالم
العربيه
والموضوع ان شاء الله غربله
فيصفى بين الجيشين
هيصفى على خير وان شاء الله حنرجع
للديمقراطيه ولشي طيب حاليا الحاصل حاصل
بين القوات المسلحه والمتمردين بالواضح
كذا يعني حتى المواطن المواطن الان ملتزم
ومنزله صاير في السودان ده خلاف بين اساس
الكبار يعني انا بعتبروا وخلاف على السلطه
وعلى الكرسي
فتنه
السودان الجيش وهو الوحيد هيقدر على كل
البلد وعلاه ما يعتقد ان الاقدار اللي
جاريه في السودان هذه كلها مطامح ومصالح
شخصيه فقط يعني الاسباب كلها هي اسباب
سياسيه واسباب هي اطماع في الكراسي وخساره
الشعب السوداني بس يعني يا حرب سلطه
وبطاعه كراسي الان شهر رمضان عشره واخر من
رمضان الان الان يتقاتلون في سبيل الكرسي
هذه مشاكل من اجل السلطه كل واحد بده
السلطه لحاله ما بيهمه الشعب شو بده
يعني الشعب يكون توحدوا مع بعض ما بيهمنا
ولا من هويدا ولا من الجيش ولا من الدعم
يعني الخساره كنا مثل بعض يعني والله يعني
شي
حرام والله العظيم بصير يعني نحن بعضنا
يعني هذا الشيء
للمواطنين لانه يلي بصير مش صالح لاي
مواطن الجنزويد والجيش ما عندهم توافق
بيناتهم كرماليات
يكون في امنعه امن تام في السودان او
استقلال تام في السودان انا بتمنى يعني
لازم
اتواصل لانه ما في شبكه وما في انترنت كل
شيء مقفول كل شيء مع طول
عوده الى دكتور حسن ابو طالب المستشار في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه من القاهره اهلا بك وانت
تحدثنا من القاهره من الضروري ان نتحدث عن
هذا الموضوع من جهه الامن القومي المصري
تحدثنا عن بعض من ذلك قبل قليل بالنسبه
الى الاقليم ولكن خاصه بالنسبه الى مصر
هذا امن قومي اساسي جدا على راس الاولويات
المصريه بدون شك اي شيء يحصل في السودان
تحديدا ما الاولويات المصريه باعتقادك في
هكذا وضع الان
وما القدرات الحقيقيه التي لديها او
الاليات التي تمتلكها للضغط
يعني في البدايه واكد يعني الموقف المصري
فيما يتعلق باشيان السوداني مصر حريصه
لاقصى درجه ممكنه على استقرار السودان
هريسه على ان يكون هناك حاله من حاله
التوافق السوداني من خلال السودانيين
انفسهم فهي تشجع كل عمليه وكل حركه تؤدي
الى هذا الهدف هدف الاستقرار العام من
السودانيين انفسهم الاليات المصريه اليد
دبلوماسيه بالدرجه الاولى واليات تتعلق
بممارسه ما يمكن ان نسميه بالعلاقات
والاتصالات مع كافه الاطراف السودانيه نحن
نعلم ان بعض الاطراف السودانيه ليست يديها
صوره ايجابيه فيما يتعلق بالدور المصري
ولديها ايضا رغبه في ان يعني توتر العلاقه
مع ما بين الشعبين المصري والسودان ولكننا
نحن هنا في مصر يعني نظره ونستبعد مثل هذه
الامور ونتعامل مع السودان باعتباره اشقاء
باعتبار جزء من القوم المصري كما ان مصر
واستقرارها هي جزء ايضا من الامن القومي
السوداني هذه هي علاقه تاريخيه وعلاقه
عضويه وعلاقه لا يمكن ان تنفصم لا من هنا
ولا من هناك وبالتالي الاستقرار الذي مص
تسعى اليه هي مصر تلعب دورا حياديا وكما
يعني انتم ذكرتم انفسكم من خلالها
التقارير المختلفه يعني لها موقف حيادي لم
تتدخل اطلاقا في الازمه السودانيه في
السنوات الماضيه وكانت تحفز الاطراف فقط
على التواصل وتحفز الاطراف على التوافق
واستضافت بعض الكثير من القيادات
السودانيه وكانت رسالتها واضحه توافقوا
وتواصلوا وانظروا للسودان باعتباره هو
البلد الذي يجب ان تحافظه عليه
والسودانيين يجب ان تحافظوا على مصالحهم
وان تساعده على تنمياتهم وعلى استقرارهم
مصر حريص على هذا في نفس الوقت لديها اليد
دبلوماسيه في التعاون مع سواء الامم
المتحده سواء جامعه الدول العربيه سواء مع
الدول العربيه المهمه والكبرى لديها ايضا
اهتمامات مماثله كان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات واي دوله عربيه اخرى
مثل الجزائر على سبيل المثال وبالتالي
فنحن امام اليات دبلوماسيه واليات تتعلق
بممارسه الحد الادنى من ما يمكن ان نسميه
بالضغط
المناسب على كل الاطراف حتى دكتور حسن
هناك الحيويه نعم هناك مخاوف حقيقيه الان
من توسع رقعه هذا الصراع خاصه اذا ما
نظرنا الى انه هناك مجموعات مسلحه تحديدا
بالخرطوم ثمانيه مجموعات مسلحه على الاقل
موجوده ربما تنتظر كفه من ستجح وستكون لها
الاولويه او هي الافضل الان لتكون الى
جانبها هل تتخوف من دخول هذه المجموعات
بهذا الصراع
يعني معلوماتي كباحث وكمراقب للوضع في
السوداني نحن نعلم جيدا هذه الجماعات
المسلحه ونعلم ان بعض هذه الجماعات
المسلحه مموله من بعض دول الجوار نعلم
ايضا ان هذه الجماعات المسلحه لديها طبع
اجرامي بشكل او باخر والبعض الاخر يتحدث
عن الديمقراطيه وعن الحريه وعن يعني اعاده
العسكريين الى الثكنات ولكن هذه كلها مجرد
دعايه فارغه من وجهه نظري على الاقل
وبالتالي نحن نراقب هذا الموضوع لكن في
نفس الوقت لا نستطيع ونتحدث بصراحه شديده
لا تستطيع ان تتدخل للقيام بما يجب ان
يقوم به السودانيين انفسهم تجاه مثل هذه
الجماعات المسلحه سواء كانت القوات
المسلحه السودانيه سواء كانت القوه
المدنيه المدنيه هنا ايضا عليها دور مهم
جدا جدا في فتح هذه الجماعات المسلحه
ومحصلاتها وايضا التعامل ضدها بكل الاسباب
حتى لا تكون هي العنصر الحاكم فيما يتعلق
بمستقبل هذه نقطه مهمه جدا اثرتها اريد ان
اتابع فيها دكتور اذا سمحت موضوع انه يعني
الحياد وقلت انه اذا كنا اكثر صراحه وانا
يعني ادعوك ايضا في هذا السؤال الى نكون
اكثر الى ان نكون اكثر صراحه لماذا كان
بالنسبه الى مصر او دول اخرى في العالم
وليس فقط مصر هنا عندما قام عبد الفتاح
البرهان مع حفظ الالقاب بتحركه
قوطع وعوقب السودان ككل واوقفت المساعدات
والى ما هنالك الان عندما قام جزء من
الجيش كان يعتبر جزء من الجيش ولكن البعض
يعتبره ميليشيات وهي قوات الدعم السريع
بمثل هذا التحرك لم يكن هناك هذا الحسم
بدعم القوات المسلحه عبر رئيسها وعبر رئيس
مجلس السياده الانتقالي ما تفسيرك
اطلاق النار كمقدمه لحل المشكلات الاخرى
بطريقه واقعيه اذا تجاوزنا هذه الواقعيه
وتصورنا امور اكبر مما تحتمل الاوضاع في
السودان فنقوم بالتالي يعني مخطئين من حيث
التصور ومخطئين من حيث الحركه انا اتحدث
هنا كمحلل سياسي وليست كمسؤول وبالتالي
انا ارى ان الامر الان هو الضغط السياسي
المكثف من خلال التنسيق مع القوه المتدخله
اماميا وافريقيا وعربيا لوقف اطلاق النار
ثم البحث بعد ذلك عن كيف يعاد الامر الى
الوضع الطبيعي الامر الطبيعي يعني
المعروفه هذه الحالات بعد وقف اطلاق النار
هدنه وبعد ذلك الحفاظ على الموارد الحفاظ
على الارواح لتقديم الدعم الانساني
والاقتصادي والدعم الاغاثي ثم بعد ذلك
التفكير في المبادئ للحل المستدام هذا هو
العرفانيه التي تفرض مثل هذه الظروف
الخاصه جدا والتي لا يمكن لاي احد ان
يتدخل فيها باكثر من ذلك من وجهه نظري اي
كلام حوالين تدخلات عسكريه من هذا الطرف
او ذاك هذا كلام يعني من وجهه كلام عبسي
ويزيد تاجيج الموقف ويزيد ايضا تفجير
السودان نحن لسنا مع تفجير السودان نحن مع
استقلال السودان والحفاظ على شعبه وعلى
موارده وعلى مواطني يعني مواقف المتشدده
الخارجيه ربما تاتي بنتائج عكسيه اذا في
الداخل ولذلك يعلو صوت الحكمه اقليميا على
الاقل الان لتغليب صوت العقل شكرا جزيلا
لك دكتور حسن تطالب المستشار في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
من القاهره شكرا لك ربما لدينا بعض
الاخبار العاجله الراويه البيت يحث
الامريكيين في السودان على توخي الحذر
وبانه لا خطط بالوقت الحالي لاجلاء
الرعايه الامريكيين من
السودان نتابع باخبارنا حيث اكد المبعوث
او افادت مصادر من السفاره الامريكيه
للعربيه بان قوات الدعم السريع استهدفت
عربه مصفحه تابعه للسفاره الامريكيه
باطلاق نحو 100 رصاصه واضافت المصادر ان
استهداف المصفحه لم يسفر عن وقوع قتلى او
اصابات
هذا واظهرت مقاطع فيديو صورا لجنود من
الجيش السوداني داخل معسكر تابع لقوات
الدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم
كما بث التلفزيون السوداني مقاطع فيديو
تظهر انتشار في شوارع الخرطوم لعدد من
المدرعات في الشوارع الرئيسيه للعاصمه
الله رب العالمين قلنا مغمضين
مبروك مبروك الحمد لله
مبروك مبروك مبروك
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا من جديد سالم
الهاشمي مراسل العربيه اهلا بك من جديد
سالم يعني هل تجددت الاشتباكات بالعاصمه
اهلا بكم بكل ساده المشاهدين الان في
منطقه بحري ايضا رجع مره اخرى عدويه قوي
جدا يظهر انه مضاد للطائرات كذلك يتم
استخدامه في هذه اللحظات او صوت مقذوفات
في المنطقه الغربيه من بحري في الاتجاه
الغربي البحري بالقرب من جسر شمبات في هذه
المنطقه لا يسمع ذوي لبعض المطلوبات او
اصوات
لسلاح ثقيل في هذه المنطقه في هذه في هذه
اللحظات تحديدا تمام اعود اليك الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول انه سفير
الاتحاد الاوروبي في السودان تعرض لاعتداء
في مقر اقامته بانتظار المزيد من التفاصيل
حول هذا الموضوع اتابع معك تذكرنا لو سمحت
بابرز يعني
تحتويه بحري منطقه بحري لكي تشهد هذه
الاشتباكات
نعم نذكر فقط الساده المشاهدين بانه
بوعيده افطار او مع الافطار بدات
الطائرات تنفذ غارات جويه من القوات
الجويه السودانيه وهي تنفذ عبر طائرات
يظهر انها تنفذ عمليه
لضرب المواقع التي تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع
بعد ذلك جاء رد من قوات الدعم السريع بعبر
مضادات الطائرات التي استخدمت بكثافه في
سماع
الخرطوم في بعيده الافطار استمر هذا الحال
اربعين الى 45 دقيقه ثم بعد ذلك هدات
الاحوال جاءت بعد ذلك الانباء التي تقول
بان قوات الدعم السريعه اسقط الطائره عبر
الدعم السريع هي التي قالت ذلك ونفى الجيش
السوداني سقوط اي طائره له خلال هذه
الحمله
ولم يثبت اي طرف من الطرفين بصوره او باي
شيء
لسقوط هذه الطائره من عدمه
بالنسبه لسؤالي اهم المنشات والقواعد
والمؤسسات الحيويه التي تضمها هذه المناطق
خاصه الخرطوم بحري لكي تشهد كل هذه
الاشتباكات
نعم
هي الاشتباكات قد لا تكون لانه مضادات
الطائرات
بحسب المصادر التي لدينا ليست فقط من بحري
هي ايضا تاتي منهم درمان بالضفه الاخرى
قبال بحري في منطقه هذه المضادات يظهر
انها تنطلق من محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون
هناك في هذا المقر لكن ايضا هناك نريد ان
ننوه ايضا الى نداءات الاستغاثه التي
ترسلها لجنه اطباء السودان وترسلها كذلك
نقابه الاطباء السودان كلهم يرسلون نداءات
للاغاثه فيما يتعلق بالمستشفيات التي
اغلقت والمهدده بالاغلاق كانت نقابه اطباء
السودان تحدثت بانه معظم المستشفيات
الكبيره والتخصصيه خرجت عن الخدمه نتيجه
اخلائها قصرا وبانه المستشفيات والمرافق
الصحيه تشهد تدهورا غير المسبوق ينظر
بانهيار القطاع كنت اود ان اسالك اعود الى
الميدانيات واللي تذكرنا باهم المناطق
التي تشهد مواجهات ما هي المناطق
نعم المناطق التي تشهد مواجهات حتى الان
كانت منطقه جبره الى ان اعلنها الجيش
السوداني انه انتهى بمهمته في جبل او انه
استولى على مخازن الذخيره والسلاح
والمعدات الموجوده في منطقه جبرا التي
شهدت نزاعا كثيفا واطلاقا كثيفا للنيران
ومضادات الطائرات وكل
ربما انواع اسلحه كثيره جدا تم استخدامها
في منطقه جبرا وشهود الاعيان هناك
والمواطنون كانوا يتحدثون عن ذعر يعم
منطقه جبرا في
الساعات الماضيه الى اعلى للجيش السوداني
السيطره على تلك المنطقه او المقر الذي
هذه الذخائر والمعدات ايضا محيط
القياده العامه ايضا بالقرب من القصر
الجمهوري كذلك المناطق النزعه هنا في بحري
في منطقه بجوار كوبري شمباد الى مقر
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في كافوري كذلك بالقرب
من المحطه الحراريه كذلك في
ايضا تشهد
اشتباكات دائما وفي ام درمان في محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون هذه هي ابرز المحطات
التي شهدت اشتباكات خلال هذا اليوم شكرا
جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من
الخرطوم وهناك تفاصيل جديده راويه على ما
يبدو بموضوع الاعتداء على سفينه الاتحاد
الاوروبيه السودان الذي وصفه بورال بانه
انتهاك صارخ لاتفاقيات ليس لدينا الكثير
من التفاصيل عن طبيعه الاعتداء واذا كان
في تحميل للمسؤوليات في هذا الموضوع واذا
كان ما كان مصير السفير سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في السودان على كل سنتابع اولا
باول هذا الموضوع قوه دعم السريع نشرت
صورا قالت انها لاسرى من الجيش السوداني
واكدت اكدت انها تتعامل معهم وفق القانون
الدولي الانساني
لغايتكم
يتوجهكم بالله
تعليم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التغطيه من العربيه متواصله على مدار
الساعه لتطورات الاحداث في السودان طبعا
الزميل صهيب شراير يتابع معكم في الساعه
القادمه الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات